Now let's define the other problem that
will be part of our example reduction.
Vertex Cover.
Given a graph G, a subset of
the vertices is a vertex cover,
if every edge is incident
on a vertex in S.
To illustrate, consider this graph here.
The two shaded vertices do
not form a vertex cover.
We haven't covered this edge here,
or this one here.
On the other hand, these two
vertices do form a vertex cover,
because every edge is
incident on one of these two.
Clearly, the set of all
vertices is a vertex cover, so
the interesting question is,
how small a vertex cover can we get?
Or, phrased as a decision question,
we're given a graph G and
an integer k,
at most the number of vertices.
The question is,
does G have a vertex cover of size k?
Note that this problem is also in NP.
It's easy enough to check whether
a subset of vertices is of size k,
and whether it covers all the edges.